ok alors comment tu vas je vais bien
tu sais juste euh
elle fait ce qu'il faut faire qu'est
-ce que ça veut dire
je suis désolé papa euh pourquoi ne pas juste
déjeuner et parler on peut faire ça bien
s'il te plaît tu penses que  tu as ça
sous contrôle je comprends pourquoi je fais des
choses ça ne me rend pas différent
tu es juste gêné parce que j'étais
comme tu sais que j'étais comme cette
chose incroyable comme ta création spéciale ou
quelque chose comme ça et tu sais comme qui je suis maintenant
ouais qui es-tu Nick ce n'est pas moi papa
ici c'est qui je suis ce n'est pas toi
ce n'est pas toi Nick qu'est-ce que tu fais
hein tu dois toujours
tout contrôler tout le temps laisse-moi laisse-moi
te baiser à l'hôtel  pendant quelques
nuits, je veux que ça se passe comme ça,
mon fils a disparu.
et je me demande son
huius je pensais que nous étions proches je pensais que
nous étions plus proches que la plupart des pères  s and
sons pourquoi je me sentais mieux que jamais alors
j'ai continué à le faire
ce n'est pas nous ce n'est pas qui nous sommes mon
fils est quelque part et je ne sais pas
ce qu'il fait je ne sais pas comment
aider  lui tu ne peux pas je n'ai pas l'impression d'
avoir une maladie
ce n'est pas comme le cancer c'est mon choix
trou en moi
je leur ai volé la famille je veux être
fier de moi
ce que tu as tu vas le retrouver
tu vas le récupérer
sais tu combien je t'aime je
t'aime plus que tout j'aime
tout tout
tout
[Musique]
toi